-Thank you, again, for coming on
the show. I appreciate it.
But last time you were here, we
were talking about the Met Gala.
-Yeah, that's right.
-We were going to go to
the Met Gala in a few days.
You get all dressed up.
You go to this beautiful event.
-My God, crazy.
-Did you have fun?
What'd you think?
-I mean, I -- okay,
first of all, Jimmy, you were
one of like the two people
that I knew at the whole thing.
So I just felt like
such a wallflower.
But I saw you. And you remember
this. I saw you.
It was like
everybody was around.
Justin Beiber had
just gotten on stage.
And, you know,
you gave me a big hug.
And you were like,
"I'm so happy you're here."
It was really nice.
It was a really nice moment.
And then, afterwards,
when I was on the steps,
I saw you on the bottom, and I
saw you flipping the barrier.
You flipped over the barrier.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause there were all these fans
on the other side of the street.
And they had been waiting
all night.
And you were like --
You're a man of the people.
You went over to say hi to them.
-That's right.
Yeah, they were chanting.
They were, like,
daring me, almost,
to jump the barrier.
-Absolutely. And you did.
[ Laughter ]
-I felt like
they were like, "Jimmy!"
And I go, "Dude, you want to
watch my climb this fence?
I'll do it."
[ Laughter ]
But it was like a fake bush
or something.
-It was.
It was like a fake bush.
And I saw you -- I saw you going
like -- I saw you testing it
to make sure that it would
take your weight.
And I kind of saw you, like,
maneuver yourself over.
So I was like, "You know, I'm
going to do the same thing."
-Maneuver myself?
I jumped over the bush.
[ Laughter ]
Jumped over.
-Did you?
-Yeah.
-Do we have a picture?
-Apparently, yeah,
I have a picture.
Oh, this is you.
-That's me.
-Wait, you jumped the bush?
-Yeah, 'cause I jumped in
after you.
'Cause I was like,
"If Jimmy Fallon is going to go
and say hi to the fans who have
been waiting all night,
for a glimpse of the stars, then
I want to do the same thing."
I wanted go and spend some time
with them.
-You're a good man.
Look, here's Simu Liu.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Clearing the bush. And then you
go right into the street.
-Mostly it's a shot of
my ass, but yeah.
-No, I love that. Alright,
so here's a picture of me.
Oh, I see what you're saying.
Well, it was --
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, they're similar --
they're similar photos.
I mean, I don't know.
I was just trying to get over --
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I can't tell.
-Our athletic ability
is kind of equal.
People kind of confuse --
-You could be my stunt double.
I tell them that all the time.
-Yeah. Thank you so much.
Appreciate it. I mean, hey,
probably going to be a sequel.
Just saying.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, I did a little
research, as I do all my guests.
But I realized we have
something in common
that I did not know about.
-Yes.
-We both worked at
Abercrombie & Fitch.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
That is correct.
-No, I think they're laughing
because they don't believe
that I would work.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I worked at
Abercrombie & Fitch.
-That's amazing.
When were you there?
[ Laughter ]
-Back when video games were --
I was in college, so I'd say
'94, '95, something like that.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. When were you there?
-I would have been 6 years old
then, so maybe not then.
[ Laughter ]
It was a college job for me.
-Me too.
-Yeah, I just remember --
I mean, it was such a status
symbol, right, to be like --
Well, first of all, like I knew
people who got scouted.
Like, you know the routine.
Like, you got scouted, like, you
know, going through the store.
Somebody would come up to you
and be like "Hi, excuse me.
Have you ever thought of working
for Abercrombie & Fitch?"
And if you had the look,
you would be offered a job.
[ Laughter ]
And so I, being like 17 years
old and super insecure,
like, I wanted very badly
to be hot.
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't realize it was
something that I can't control.
So I would, like, go through
the store on my own.
And I would just be like
pretending to go through
clothes and being like...
[ Laughter ]
Like, you know, "Excuse me, do
you need help with anything?"
And I'd be like "Oh, me?
No, no, I'm [Chuckles] okay."
[ Laughter ]
And I never got asked, you know,
one single time.
So this went on for a bit longer
than I'd like to admit.
And then one day, I was finally
like, "You know what?
Simu, you just got to take your
destiny into your own hands."
I walked into that Abercrombie
& Fitch with a résumé.
And I remember asking
for the manager.
The manager's name was Brandon.
He was wearing --
-That's one of the parts of
getting hired.
You had to be named Brandon.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to go through Brandon.
He had, like, ripped jeans.
-Yeah.
-He was training to be
a firefighter, you know.
And he looks me up and down
and he was like, "Eh, okay."
And he invited me to do a group
interview, which I slayed.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you became an employee.
-And I became an employee.
Although, they call them --
they don't call them employees.
They call them models.
I was a "model."
-I think they changed the name
after I worked there.
[ Laughter ]
I worked there
before they opened.
'Cause I -- and I went
in there --
[ Laughter ]
They weren't open.
I was putting shelves
on the wall and stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Oh, got it.
-That's probably why
they hired me.
-Doing construction
for Abercrombie.
-Yeah, "You can work in
the backroom or something.
Just don't be in front
of the house."
But I would go shirtless
and just...
[ Laughter ]
...stock the shelves.
-Did they want you
to go shirtless?
-No, no, no. I got in
a lot of trouble for that.
[ Laughter ]
But I went with my roommate,
because if you did get
a job there,
they would give you a free shirt
and a free pair of pants.
-Oh, yeah. Nice, nice.
-It's not free, but they give it
so you can wear that
as a uniform.
So he got a different shirt
and pants,
and then we would like swap.
-Swap.
We were like "The Sisterhood of
the Traveling Pants."
-Nice. Nice.
[ Laughter ]
-And so that was
our college wardrobe.
And then, once it opened,
we quit.
-Fair enough.
[ Laughter ]
-Couldn't take it, man.
I was like, "No."
How long did you last there?
-You know, it's really
the status of it was so --
like, I loved being able to tell
my friends that I worked at
Abercrombie & Fitch so much.
It took a long time.
-Is this when you were in
the dance troupe?
-Yeah, around the same time.
-We almost talked about it
last time,
because I loved the name
of your team.
-Yeah.
-What was it? Like cowboys --
-No, it was Hip-Hop Western.
-Yeah.
-Hip-Hop Western.
-Hip-Hop Western was --
-Western, yeah, 'cause Western
was the name
of the university
that I went to --
University of Western Ontario.
[ Cheers ]
Yes!
-No one's ever heard of that
in their lifetime.
[ Laughter ]
Western Ontario.
So wait.
And so you were Hip-Hop Western.
-Hip-Hop Western. That's right.
We came fourth place
at the provincial college
hip-hop competition.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, um...
-That goes on your résumé
immediately?
-You know, immediately.
-Did you have a go-to move?
Do you have a signature move?
-I don't think I was good enough
to have a signature --
Well, we have styles, right?
And, like, if you were a member
of, like, the 2008/2009,
it was all like, "So you think
you can dance."
It was like pop and lock,
"America's Best Dance Crew."
So we were all doing that,
like the robot and the body
waves and stuff.
-You think you still got
a little in you?
-Oh, man.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, okay, if he's gonna --
Okay.
-We got a beat going?
Roots, want to give him a beat?
-I'm not sure if it's working.
♪♪
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
♪♪
Yes!
More with Simu Liu
after the break! Stick around!
♪♪